welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question
[Music]
the big question of course is a podcast
that gives you too much information
about how
whoever your favorite batman is you are
wrong
wrongs are wrong so you get
nothing you lose good day sir
we got the data to prove it my friends
i'm eric voss here with me is my good
friend tommy bechtold hello good to see
you to be here good to see you as well
cheers
cheers hmm i'm ready to talk they're
gonna even say
what they gonna do she asked me the
whole thing and i didn't even do a what
we're celebrating this coming week
because it's gonna be dc's fandom event
where we're finally gonna get some
details
about things like james gunn suicide
squad matt reeves the batman and zack
snyder's
justice league cut for hbo max
it's gonna be very interesting to see
which batman wins this weekend because
both of them are very highly anticipated
is it going to be batfleck is it gonna
be battenson
either way you're wrong you're wrong
because in the world of dc
there are right and there are wrong
answers and everyone's wrong 100 of the
time uh hit me with that question
tom all right eric i have been wondering
as have most of our fans and then trip
lightly on this
which batman is the best batman
oh uh okay um this is a crazy question
to ask right but it's also crazy because
yes we know
everyone's kind of been waging this
nerdy debate for years and years and
years and
we've even kind of talked about it
before but we're going to do it
differently because we want to be nerdy
and quantitative
about things as always we're going to do
our best to
remove our personal whim would you like
to do this exercise with us and pull out
your own trauma strands
pull out your own problems that are
choking we're going to check our
opinions at the door
and we're not gonna think about whether
or not a certain batman spoke to
us individually at a certain time in our
lives or continues to speak to us
in reoccurring dreams that we don't
really tell too many people about
you ready to go fight some crime let's
go find some crime what do you say
not even our therapists that we don't go
to no that's true
here's what we're gonna do um we're
gonna go through all the live-action
cinematic batman that we've seen and
we're gonna rate each of them
on six categories as as data-driven as
we can uh
first important category that every
batman needs to have is intelligence
it's the world's greatest detective
right so instead of superpowers batman
has a brain
um he also has billions of dollars but
he has a brain and he knows how to spend
the money wisely
so really we want to ask is this batman
appropriately clever for his world
now we're also going to look at of
course fighting skills because
batman packs a punch sometimes he packs
a
power he's got to be fun to watch fight
yeah he's a superhero at the end of the
day
how fun is this batman to watch in the
ring that's i think that's only fair
um the third thing we're gonna look at
is the gear okay so
batman is about his toys
so that includes the batmobile the suit
the weapons the bat cave of that movie
is it all very
cool
cool and by cool i mean is it like a a
creative mix of tech that works
practically in cool ways just
uh beyond the mere visual spectacle if
some batman is just all about the look
but like is it both the look and the way
it works in the story in cool ways
the fourth dimension theatrics so batman
is a performer and a sociopath he's
gotta be versatile
yeah he's gotta both strike fear into
the hearts of criminals as
batman but he also must fool those other
gothamites as the
convincing egotistical bruce wayne
identity yeah
so it's important when you're
considering any batman it's not just
batman it's also how well they do the
bruce wayne side of it
but also there's a third dimension that
i think a lot of us overlook
is like the true bruce wayne in between
those two
who is he when he's alone sulking in the
batcave talking to alfred
is there like another third distinct
identity there that we
can relate with because that's gotta be
the batman who like tugs at our
heartstrings
and we want to see succeed not that not
the crazy
fearful silhouette and not the smug
[ __ ] billionaire
there's the third guy and i think a good
the best batman's play all three
agreed although i do enjoy the traipsing
around the fountain
version of bruce wayne with supermodels
that is my
favorite bruce wayne and also a dream of
mine
that's the one you relate with because
you're still playing that whole american
dream game
that's right you think that trickle
down's going to trickle right down to
you but it's right it stays in those
rich people's fountains and it never
flows anywhere else
i won't rest until every citizen has a
fountain and three super models to play
with uh
that's that's that's my campaign promise
i believe in tommy
all right so the fifth dimension and
this one's a bit harder to define but i
think it's very very important
comics thematic accuracy so yes batman
comics have evolved and they shifted in
tone over the decades there's lots of
different versions of batman in the
comics but at the heart of all batman
comics are some
constants some values batman's a loner
batman's vengeful he's a vigilante but
he doesn't
kill you know he usually values human
life enough because he doesn't want to
cross that line
into the rest of the rogues gallery also
he's got he's a man of ego he sleeps
around
and simply he just knows how to work a
cow
and at the end of the day that that's a
very very important thing
uh for all for all cinematic batman and
the sixth thing
we opened up to the audience we have an
audience score
uh that we put up on our community
channel uh but
we will be waiting those percentages
because we realize most of our subs are
really young mainstreamers
you guys have officially made me lose my
marbles us for these answers
and yeah we don't like raw unchecked mob
rule and uh a lot of people don't know
who kevin conroy is um because they're
born here
we'll be fair we're taking your vote
into account but we're not gonna let it
dominate it okay
we're suppressing your vote which is
also the american dream
we're bringing that electoral college
back and we will not be allowing vote by
mail for this you will not be voting by
mail
you gotta show up in person no mask
and scream your name all right let's
start really at the bottom no surprises
here
george clooney batman uh he was in one
movie joel schumacher's
batman and robin uh so starting with
intelligence we rated him a two out of
ten
because this is batman had his stupidest
yeah he really lets
uh mr freeze poison ivy bane get way
too far in that insane plot to freeze
gotham and then like
he's smart at some moments but others he
really just lets his bat boner blind him
after
ivy's gorilla dance i guess he go he
gets some points because he figures out
how to angle those satellites to melt
gotham but i don't know i think he's
pretty stupid what do you think
i couldn't agree more and uh i feel like
this movie's gonna be all about the
visuals
like there's something like we're gonna
have arnold schwarzenegger as mr freeze
like we're trying new things this is
like when like when a new animator comes
in and draws your comics and it's like
those aren't what they look like and
like you try to be open-minded and i'll
be honest like every five years i try
and tell myself like
you have to go back and watch batman and
robin like you have to go back and give
it another chance
and then like by the time arnold
schwarzenegger gets his second cold
theme pun out i'm like what killed the
dinosaurs
the ice age man even as a kid i felt
condescended by things
so yeah i think that's fair i think
that's very fair yeah and
unfortunately this batman is exactly as
smart as the movie he's in
that's not awfully pc what about that
person
and then that applies to all the other
categories as well fighting skills it's
not fun to watch
fight the nipples the butts the sack
close-ups yeah can we just get like
close-ups of bulges
yeah i love a good bulge close-up trust
me but uh
even in the yeah this move is gratuitous
he has a batman credit card
it's like the campy 1960s adam what's
batman but none of the charm
yeah none of the charm yeah well because
i i think it's george clooney's
obviously one of the most charming
people alive so you would think like
yeah but i think probably
in his mind he had to play batman a
certain way
and that was less like adam west and
more like he
if he had played it like adam west
batman it probably would have totally
worked
he almost played it like danny ocean as
batman like
his take on that and i i mean i don't
want to spend too much time on cleaning
that because yes clooney is a really
good actor but in this movie he just
looks really bored and uncomfortable he
really isn't trying
he was also written to be a pretty lame
character like his main emotional stakes
are tied to alfred's sickness yeah and
alfred doesn't even die
it's just really weird and then going to
comic thematic accuracy i gotta give
this a one out of ten just because
really the only thing that makes this
guy that we see batman is that
characters call him batman and that he
wears the cow
but like yeah so i there's really
nothing
that seems like this doesn't even feel
like a batman movie and
to be fair to clooney he did apologize
in 2014. he admits that this movie was
not right
and he didn't know what he was doing and
he just took the role because he's like
well if someone offers you batman you
gotta take it
and thank god we made him feel compelled
to apologize thank god for all the
things that has happened in his life
he's like the thing i really feel that i
owe the public an apology for
is making batman and robin i'm so sorry
the nipples didn't even produce milk
what was the point of putting them on
the suit
he did get a couple votes in the
comments of our poll so he gets an
audience score of two out of ten
but in total out of a total score of 60
points he gets eight so well not not
great
no surprises there but we do have some
surprises in the next one on our list
val kilmer batman and batman forever
he gets a nine out of ten for
intelligence and here's why
he really deserves some credit for being
one of the brainier batmans we've seen
if you go back and re-watch this movie
he is pretty smart throughout the film
he shuts down enigma
right away when he's pitching these
crazy ideas and he's able to work
through most of riddler's riddles
pretty quickly he struggles a bit but he
gets through them all
and he asks the right questions about
the vox when enigma makes it big
you know he he resists society pressure
and he's kind of like the smart ass he's
like
and what prevents you from extracting
images out of the mind
my boy's weighted smile and then at the
end of the day he tricks
riddler with a riddle of his own uh but
it's really just like
one that's designed to stall and
distract riddler as he prepares his
batarang and his night vision goggles
and then he
ends up overwhelming harvey dent with
all the dozens of coin flips
he's not a 10 out of 10 because he does
let drew barry barrymore outsmart him
with a glow stick
that's right uh overall pretty smart who
who amongst us living in l.a hasn't been
duped by drew barrymore at least once
especially with glow sticks
what is she doing with that why is she
here i don't know she's
like she's always at a rave i will say
his better action was just like
shattering glass
in big slow motion ways throughout the
movie but it looks pretty cool
he lands some solid hits on two faces
goons nothing to write home about but a
good five out of ten i'd say agreed i
agree
for gear i will say it's really just
like
um tim burton's design but everything
was polished and turned to shiny chrome
he does get some cool points for like
the batmobile has some cool moves he's
got that cool fireproof cape
that looks pretty tight but i will say
his bat cave is just like annoyingly
vulnerable
to riddler's destruction and he has his
cool bat boat and bat playing they both
immediately get shot down
by their stupid battleship game so uh
again he's right in the middle of the
road there
five out of ten plus he didn't have the
fake lips for kissing
he could use those would have helped
theatrics wise
and i want to know your take on this
tommy i think kilmer bruce was
a very smooth ego driven but he didn't
really do enough to differentiate that
from his batman
like no he's got those awesome pouty
lips
oh man oh man shove those under any cow
and i'm there i'm there
but like he's he's very boring as batman
he doesn't scare anyone
he's just kind of flat like it was just
this thing in the 90s where
people just took the wrong thing away
from keaton's batman and like
said oh maybe he was too charactery and
i'm just going to make him more boring
what do you think
i i will say the my biggest reason for
agreeing with you is i can barely
remember
his personality and i can remember the
plot of the movie
i can remember specific moments but i
don't remember his performance
really especially as bruce wayne yeah
and in fairness like
jim carrey as the riddler takes over
that movie
and then he got like tommy lee jones
who's like [ __ ] uh yosemite sam
yeah he like saw jim carrey like doing
some improv in that movie and was like
tommy lee jones is also gonna do some ad
living and he's going to go a little
bigger than you
used to start
at the end of the day his total was uh
30
out of 60. uh so significantly better
than george clooney i don't think it's
fair to say he's that bad he's
significantly better than clooney
definitely several levels up for sure
so now we're gonna move on to a beloved
one that some of you may be pissed off
as not higher on the list but we're just
trying to do our best to be accurate
here adam west
batman of course 60s tv series he was in
one movie batman the movie 1966
it flopped here's the thing okay so for
intelligence we gave him six out of ten
not because he's dumb it's because he is
insanely smart
like he never gets outsmarted he like
immediately out-thinks everybody
here take my bat radio i looked it up
this morning
that class of missile receives on a
wavelength
of 164.1 and he never shows his work
like he's we never see him struggle to
figure anything out now that is part of
the chart
but i will say and i want to bring this
back over and over convenient
intelligence
is not real detective work no so he's
not really the world's greatest
detective he just has god level
intelligence
that kind of takes you out of it yeah i
was gonna say he is kind of a god
in in that show like in the way that
like macgyver is kind of a god in
macgyver where it's like
it's like these characters should be
dead a lot
but they are somehow immortal
like that is their power batman does
have a superpower his immortality like
like in the first batman 66 movie
alone where he saved from a missile by
a brave dolphin it was noble of that
animal to hurl himself into the path of
that final torpedo from that moment on
you're like all right so you're immortal
obviously uh and you know when it comes
to fighting skills we give a four out of
ten
because we do love uh any punch that
ends with a yes a biff
a biff yeah adam west pulled off some
solid acrobatics and stunts with bert
ward they're really fun to watch and you
know what adam west didn't feel the need
to get ripped
no i i found that impressive i respect
that nobody
messes with adam we now let's talk about
his gear because this batman
loves his toys oh yes oh that's
the best part so we give him a seven out
of ten for this yeah because he's got
all kinds of crap
um and a lot of them were ahead of their
time he had like small computers he had
tracking devices infrared glasses
this was rivaling what we saw in the
dead serious double 07 movies in the
1960s
but all of it is stamped with like a
bright yellow
bat logo branding on point
you definitely had a yeah you got a
brand manager for sure
and a lot of it is just like real
bonkers gear and it's really just
written to be convenient quick solutions
like he's got amnesia gas and counter
hypnosis pellets
just in case famously shark repellent
yeah
again my thing is you gotta show the
work the gear is
part of the fun of the show but it's
definitely over the top
as are the theatrics um uh 7 out of 10
on theatrics because adam west batman
was freaking hilarious he made the
character popular
i i i love it you know it's it's pure
vaudevillian camp but it's
you know at the end of the day it is a
bit one-dimensional which is totally
forgivable because the series was meant
for teenagers in the 60s
um but it it just kind of was like the
first step for
later takes to uh better explore the
depths of bruce wayne's character
um which we we need we need in this
ranking but he still gets you know
some solid points here the problem is
when it comes to comic thematic accuracy
two out of ten
because obviously this was not the goal
right
like they had the action word aesthetic
from the comics yeah that's about as far
as it tries to
it has more in common with the other 60s
series like uh
you know there's a lot of celebrity
guest stars cultural trends that they
just kind of worked in there without
thinking of the logic of it there's like
hippies and beatniks
king tut shows up in an episode
oh and if you and by the way just a note
for viewers if you have access to the
series
treat yourself to the liberace episode
where he plays two roles
he plays the piano player shondell and
then he also plays shondell's evil mean
mafia cousin tony
who forces him to commit crimes it's the
best
it's my favorite episode of that show
because it's liberace trying to act very
butch
when he's playing the game it's so good
it's so good
but you know he got a pretty good
audience score six out of ten
he did reign as the batman in in
many people's minds for like decades so
he scores pretty well 32 out of 60
combined score on our list
the the next one who replaced him in
many people's minds is the definitive
batman michael keaton batman
tim burton's batman 1989 and oh yes
burns a few years later
so let's talk about him oh great batman
intelligence wise
a solid detective he uses research he
uses media savvy
spur of the moment thinking he uses that
platter to shield himself for when he's
fighting the joker but he can't expose
himself as batman
he he flips through newspaper archives
to break the story on oswald cobblepot
he
uses you know 90s media tech of that uh
dvd
to expose penguin i will say uh keaton
batman is smart enough for his world
i i watched adam west batman first and
then begged my parents to let me see
michael keaton batman because i think i
was
only six when it came out but like i
associated him as so much more serious
than adam west like at the time like it
was like watching
uh like slapstick comedy like animal
house versus citizen kane
maybe he had a heart attack holy [ __ ]
yeah i was like this is the real scary
batman
this is the fun like diet coke batman
now on uh onto fighting skills we gave
him a four out of ten
and that's not necessarily keaton's
fault because like the
his batman's physicality was really
limited by his costume and
and burton wasn't so much of a stunts
choreographer at all
[Music]
i like to think of it as tim burton is
all about the frame like the
before and the after of the storyboard
not the arrow
in that storyboard the movement in
between not to say he can't do it it's
just he's more about like the specific
visual and that's why
tim burton is so iconic is you can take
a still frame from his movies
and know exactly all the meaning and the
tone of that shot
whereas like film is a kinetic art form
it is about the movement and about the
sequence
yeah so his movies look like paintings
uh which they're beautiful there's a lot
of moments that aren't so vibrant
now let's talk about the gear most of
his gear was for like quick escapes and
and spying like he has a lot of
repelling lines he climbs he swings he
has smoke bombs
uh at the end of the day burton was more
about the spectacle than functionality
though
burton kind of gave the villains the
gear and in an insanely impractical way
like it was like
boys like the wind-up toys that explode
for penguin and like
yeah didn't the joker have a blimp now
uh for keaton theatrics
we gave him an 8 out of 10 because
keaton is a masterful
physical comedian he's got broad range i
mean he just played beetlejuice before
this
it's showtime he really brings like this
manic
sociopathic energy to the role and he
does a great job creating distinct
physicalities and identities for both
bruce and for batman i will say he's
great at flipping the switch
into batman mode he lowers his register
his iconic voice
but he's kind of like uh he gets like
nervous he plays a grounded everyman as
bruce wayne
but he doesn't really seem like a kind
of guy who's running a fortune 500
company
no now when it comes to comics thematic
accuracy
this movie does take a hit three out of
ten because while burton's batman is
totally iconic it's
not at all for the same reasons the
batman comics are beloved
yeah it's a burton movie at the end of
the day yes and that is what people love
about it
but it's more burton than batman and uh
and they both
keaton and burton deserve a ton of
credit for popularizing the character
making it like so profitable and beloved
like they were able to
sell this in so many different forms and
make
so much freaking money and really bring
millions of readers back to the comics
and make people
find and discover what batman's really
all about which i think is great
we gave a 7 out of 10 for the audience
score adjusted with a total point value
of 36 out of 36
not bad not bad emotionally i would have
ranked him higher but that's just me
we're trying to remove our own trying to
remember you're right as much keeping my
body even though we're also opining on
each of these categories
let's move on to some people who helped
us make this episode
first off thanks to our friends at uh
coors light for always giving us
something great to drink
this summer obviously it's been a
different one
things like festivals concerts movies
they're getting pushed back they've been
changed but summer itself
has not been canceled and coors light
wants to help you chill this summer
take a break from the stresses and
pressures of daily life well eric as you
know whenever i'm babysitting i like to
treat the kids to a round of course like
i'm just kidding we can't do the kids
there were over 21 that you're
babysitting yeah i made babysit
uh a group of identical triplets they're
35 years old
and they're circus performers flat out
they are trapeze artists they're called
the flying graysons if you're a trapeze
artist
especially if you're part of the flying
graysons don't do it before you uh no
you want to drink responsibility don't
drink and trap guys oh no as always of
course
eric you know i've said this before this
is the official beer of my uncle doug
he's had a refrigerator
in the garage where he sneaks his
cigarettes full of coors light
since i can remember since i was old
enough to start getting asked hey do you
want a beer so i
think of all the dough with my cooler
slate now the new course light summer
can
does the work for you it uh features
sunglasses that literally turn
blue when the beer is cold and ready to
drink it's really the perfect beer for
chilling as it's cold crisp really just
a hundred and five calories that's why
coors light is the one
i choose when i need a moment of chills
so when you need to reset the summer
reach for the beer that's
made to chill yeah you can have coarse
light delivered by going to
get.coorslight.com and finding local
delivery options near you
celebrate responsibly coors brewing
company golden colorado
bam um but let's move on with this
this placement i think is gonna be the
most controversial the fact that we put
it over keaton
so will arnett lego batman hear us out
here from his appearance in the lego
movie franchise
so intelligence-wise we rated him six
out of ten because at the end of the day
he's a parody
of other on-screen batman's that we've
seen he's really a smart ass he's aware
he's still aware of his own tropes
hey guys i think we're about to crash
into the sun yeah but it's gonna look
really cool he's kind of a man child who
quickly
claims credit for ideas yeah i already
knew that that's kind of who he is
um and he's he's not really an
independent actor in his world
he's exactly as smart as the animators
and screenwriters
are for those movies he's like a piece
he's a toy of the machinery of this toy
universe
uh and it's very clever in a meta sense
but he's he's not
really like maximum intelligence batman
as we know him to be
but really all of his gear is part of
the meta commentary of this
so it's all a joke meant to reflect the
character's over-the-top ego
like the unlimited nature of his tech is
part of this movie's
really commentaries on capitalism on the
version of batman built by the burton
movies that they're really designed to
sell merch
and that's what i think is part of the
genius of the lego batman
is like that is that has become part of
the batman mythology
is that like on a meta level he's kind
of a sellout and the rest of you get
back and it's kind of really fun to see
that
addressed in these movies and that's
where i think theatrics he gets a lot of
points for eight out of ten uh because
in addition to parodying other batman
takes
will arnett really hits the right note
he brings a lot of bojack horsemen into
this
role especially in the lego batman he
explores like the ego
and the loner attitude of the character
but like just as a concept they're able
to explore him through a lot of
different angles
uh comic thematic accuracy he gets a six
out of ten
it's really hard to judge because he is
a meta parody
but he has a commentary on the
commercialization of the brand that is
very much part of its history
and it's just very interesting that we
have this version of batman
i can see the argument that he should be
in a separate category from the other
ones that we've seen
um but if you do want to include him i
think this is where he should rank on
the list
uh audiences gave him a score out of
five out of ten bringing his total
just above keaton just just above
just 37 out of 60. wow well
all right i guess since it's only like a
point above i'm a little more
understanding
i was seething inside when you first
said that he was above him
okay now we're going to move on starting
with ben affleck
from uh zach snyder films batman v
superman suicide squad justice league
justice league
part one and the real justice league
coming out next year
so i think ben affleck batman is
extremely
underrated he's not given enough credit
let's start with intelligence though
we gave him a seven out of ten for
intelligence because yes
affleck batman does show some practical
insights in his battles with the man of
steel
and his attempts to save life in
metropolis at the beginning of that
movie
he's extremely impressive the way he can
track down barry allen and arthur curry
uh he's just like here's the issue when
the justice league mixes
the smartest one in the room should be
batman he should
he should criticize everyone else's
plans as over
thought or naive but in these movies and
maybe you could blame
joss whedon the way he kind of like
restructured justice league
he but even in batman v superman ben
affleck batman's like the
seventh smartest person in that movie
whenever he's talking
alfred or when he's when he's talking to
diana they kind of like
make him the dumber one in all those
conversations and it's just like
he doesn't seem like the smartest one in
the room in those movies
so i can't give him more than 7 out of
10 for intelligence
i think he's underrated in almost all
reviews of him but i think that
he's fairly rated here now we have to
say
first 10 out of 10 on our list fighting
skills there is
no debate this is by far the most fun
batman to watch fight
man zack snyder just gets it when it
comes to stunts
and movement like the guy appreciates
stunt work and he makes
beautiful looking fights whether it's
the 300 or whether it's made of steel or
whether it's or it's batman v superman
it's gorgeous like the punch is land
heavy the fights have clarity and
coherence
far above the nolan films really i would
say it's similar to the movement of the
arkham games you know
like you can feel like yeah like there's
like a vibration pack
as you're fighting along with him the
moment he throws superman down that
stairwell and smashes a sink on his head
you feel
every hit it's great it's beautiful now
when it comes to the gear though we gave
him a six out of ten because yeah his
gear is super militarized he comes up
with some real clever [ __ ] with that
crypt tonight
but like it's armored up to a deadly
degree
it's like designed mostly to inflict
damage as opposed to like the clever
alternate uses that batman gear is
supposed to be like everything just
looks like he's going into war which i
know was the nature of
batman v superman but like he doesn't
really seem to have
a lot of nuance with it now i love that
he uses the gun disablers
but he also uses guns batman should not
use guns
i'm sorry he shouldn't fire a gun this
batman is like the blunt
force batman in every way like he's
bigger
he's a wider batman he's like his
his attacks are way more brutal
you got him
he learned his lesson there's not a lot
of subtlety in his movements there's not
a lot
there's not a lot of like elegance to it
that's like almost like a frank miller
thing like you know like frank miller's
batman is always very brutal
and like very very much about like
caving people's faces in but yeah the
gun thing bumped me as well like
especially when he's shooting the
machine gun and like the
future vision dream sequence thing and
he's got the he's got the duster out and
he's just
blowing people when he's mowing people
down like yeah that was uh
that was weird now when it comes to
theatrics we gave him a seven out of ten
because
we do think ben affleck's performance
deserves more credit
like man just re-watch that opening
scene in batman v superman where he's
running through the streets he's trying
to save people i'm like this is
batman like i miss this like i want to
see more of this
he's really good at playing super smug
when he's talking to clark
and diana and alfred i'm like this guy
is a freaking socialite
who like would go to these parties and
talk down to people like affleck is so
good at that and when he's talking down
to arthur and barry later
in in justice league it's really great i
will say
it seems like joss whedon unfortunately
just kind of watered him down into like
a lamer version of iron man with all
those jokes in his
justice league what are your superpowers
again
i'm rich but it's not just all whedon
i mean snyder and batman v superman
really made his rage against superman
too much of a forced mess i think it
happens too fast he he hit the right
notes to
structure it up to the point it it
doesn't feel
that motivated and i think people were
just like what are you talking about we
saw him be mad we saw him fight
i think there's a lot of people these
days who are watching movies and don't
understand what a true emotional arc is
and they're just like
yep he checked the block we saw the
actor i know be angry and throw
something
you're not hungry either okay
okay it's fun
but it just it doesn't make sense and
there's just too much raw violence and i
think batman always works better
instead of raw violence he uses symbolic
fear
rather than actual like punching
but still not a bad score and then now
when it comes to comic thematic accuracy
we gave him a six out of ten and we
understand there's some controversy here
because yes zack snyder's batman is like
a frank miller
version he's a dark knight returns
batman you know he's a bit older he's
fixated on stopping superman he's an
obsessive he's suffered losses he's
haunted
and yes batman has gotten really violent
in a lot of the comics we we understand
that
but as tommy and i were saying we can't
forgive him for spraying bullets around
and breaking necks
like he has such a high body count in
these movies not just like
parademons human beings that he tortures
he clearly has very little regard for
actual human life and that would be okay
in certain batman stories but this is a
batman
who at the beginning of that movie made
his whole moral argument
against superman one based on the value
of human life and collateral damage
so that strips his entire argument away
from him in that conflict
which just makes it meaningless and
groundless
yeah there's just too much it's just too
much too much brute force and not enough
humanizing of the character or enough
remorse or at least
concerned about what he's doing concern
for his actions he's kind of a
remorseless thug
and it could be explained if it was like
he's just
he's just numb now like if they made
more of a point of
saying like he just feels nothing
anymore because everyone he's ever loved
is gone or
has either left him or died because a
vision's softly
creeping but it's just we get the one
visual
of robin's suit with like hahaha written
on it and like that's supposed to be
enough to be like this is why batman is
now a nihilist
and he does enough good things to make
you
know that that's not true you know that
he does have a heart and have compassion
but it just doesn't
it doesn't it's too uneven uneven is a
is a really good word for it tommy
because i think that's what a lot of
people are super defensive of batman v
superman is they're like
what are you talking about here's an
example of when he did exactly what you
think there needs to be more of
like films don't work that way they
don't work like oh i threw in this
it's not like a big pot where it's like
i threw in some garlic in there so it's
fine
it is about the balance of it if there's
so much other [ __ ] in the movie to
distract you from like the core dynamic
like then yeah if i don't know if i no
longer relate to
the characters the main character's main
objective
because like you put in everything of
everything else in the movie
then like yeah you you screwed up you
know that's stories aren't about like
telling everything all at once it's
about like keeping focus
on the main objective and i think that
was definitely lost in batman v superman
however
our audience gave it a score of they
voted him second
in terms of their favorite batman take
that as he will so he gets to score at
nine out of ten for the audience score
bringing his grand total to
45 out of 60. um very good very good
score for backfly
all right so now we're moving on to the
top two
this one many of you may have top on
your list but it comes on second on our
list
christian bale from the dark knight
trilogy oh my god
so he is a very very good batman
but let's break it down so intelligence
nine out of ten
bales batman is very very smart he
smartly applies insights into gotham's
criminal justice system he understands
that it takes
thorough policing and prosecution to
really stop crime in a city he lets
others get the wins
but you know he does stupidly kind of
let joker and bane trap him
every once in a while he gets a little
lucky every now and then
but because this batman's brain is
powered by christopher nolan himself
i would say this is one of the smartest
batman's that we've seen
now fighting skills
he learned his lesson uh six out of ten
um because he's not very fun to watch
fight
leaves much to be desired this is i
think most people's criticism with the
nolan trilogy
like he gets his ass kicked in some
really cool ways but like
the moments where he's supposed to be
fun to watch fight
it's just like nolan doesn't really know
where to put the camera he's just kind
of like i'll use the steadicam
and kind of spin it around the
characters but our character is supposed
to be fighting in shadows so i'm not
going to light anything
nolan got much better at this as the
series went on it's like
after he shot inception he's like oh
stunts can be fun to shoot
oh a whole investment more time in this
and so
when dark knight rises come around like
yeah you get some cool fighting in there
but at the end of the day thematically
he'd already structured his batman to
not be like a hand-to-hand warrior he's
more of a stage performer
who like overwhelms his enemies by
getting them to fail to notice their
surroundings
that tends to be how each one of them
dies they are
they aren't understand where they're
standing and then luckily selena kyle
comes in
and shoots bane off them into a pillar
gear
10 out of 10. oh this
this batman the tech ah the highest
achievement i think of this batman
everything he uses is uh
painstakingly grounded in real world
military tech
you see him assemble it he shows all of
his work and it's
cool to watch him use this stuff now
i'll say the tumbler as a batmobile
loses a bit points on aesthetic i prefer
a batmobile that like looks like a
batmobile as much as it looks like a
tank
but nolan was even kind of aware of this
he blew it up in the dark knight and
turned into this awesome looking back
pod
yeah so like he kind of like you see him
improving
on his mistakes as he goes and it's kind
of fun to watch that
the anti-camera tech that bruce wayne
uses what he's watching yeah yeah
that's persuaded any shorts out of
everybody's cameras is really cool yeah
it really it's lucious fox who should
get all the points on this one but the
fact that nolan recognized lucious fox
as an asset well i think yeah the
the involvement of that character in
these movies successfully is a testament
of like
yeah this was a long overdue inclusion
and like it gave more of a justification
as to like how does
bruce wayne get all this stuff done it's
like oh
he does it he has a genius doing it for
him under the guise of wayne tech
you know and theatrics theatrics he also
gets a 10 out of 10 because this is what
this batman is all about and
not only do we see it they explain to us
the process and the themes behind it
so christian bale i would say is the
um most talented actor to portray this
character he both aces wayne's smug ego
and we see that in batman begins in the
dark knight but he
also plays this animalistic monstrous
batman
with a voice i'm not wearing hockey pads
and a bit it's a bit over the top and
silly he does sometimes
lose himself in that but it's a cool
choice that i think
really works my imitation of the voice
is always celebratory like i just think
it's fun
now um we're going to talk about omic
thematic accuracy here because
um eight out of ten solid points here
nolan's batman
is like i would say long halloween
detective batman which which i loved
but at the end of the day his three
movies batman is not the main character
of his movies
gotham is the main character of the
movies that's part of what makes them
great
because it's a story about human nature
about society as a whole it's a
microcosm for
for what all of us are are thinking so
it so it's hard to say that like his
batman is the one driving it he's really
like a symptom of this city which i
think is really smart but it's like
it takes away from like batman from it
being a true batman story
but he doesn't kill and that's a big
challenge for him when he faces the
joker and he really does
hit some great notes of loneliness that
brooding vengeance he's haunted
i will say i miss some of the snark
because batman is supposed to be a bit
snarky he's not
that snarky no i will also say he's a
bit too fixated on rachel dawes for two
years
but he was number one in our audience
score by
the margin far too wide in my opinion
but he gets 10 out of 10
bringing his total score for 53 out of
60.
my god who beat him well tommy that
would be
our man the legend kevin conroy voice
of the animated batman from the animated
series from the dc au films including
mask of the phantasm and many
of the batman games oh yeah many of you
may be scratching your head right now
some of you are saying yes thank god
here is why we
have to put kevin conrad at the top of
it intelligence
10 out of 10. in the world of his
stories
he has been through it all he salutes
through every conceivable
scenario in case he fails at the right
times and succeeds at the right times
he's a true procedural detective
and each time he's able to come up with
a solution that is uniquely tailored to
his enemies
i would say at the end he's just as
smart as he needs to be for his world
and he'll never like feel like oh god
like you never
are that frustrated when you're watching
him when he gets to theatrics we give
him a nine out of ten
just because there's not a huge
transformation between bruce and batman
no um it's just kevin conroy does a
little subtle thing to change his voice
but it's he's the same bulk and it's
amazing that like no one in this world
could be like
wow bruce wayne is jacked bruce wayne
has massive shoulders
shoulders are go out like this and then
he puts the batsuit on and it's the same
length of shoulders
but this is where we have to recommend
watching these animated uh films
mask of the phantasm and the rest
because they explore his soul
in such an interesting way and you
really get to know characterization
and part of that is because we've had so
many of them and we've only had three
nolan films we've only had like a couple
ben affleck once keaton was only in two
of them so they've had a lot more time
to explore it but i think that
lends itself to why it's one of the
greatest ones the fact that he's been
around for decades
and people are still like yes give us
more give us more so that's why
comic thematic accuracy 10 out of 10 and
just because
tommy i think you and you understand
this too for
true batman fans the voice of kevin
conroy is the best that we hear when
we're reading the comics when
when i read the dark knight returns i
was hearing kevin conroy's voice and my
name
for every on-screen version we've seen
of batman
they are variations on a theme it feels
like the director is putting their voice
into the work
and so many times it's been great but
the theme
that they are you know doing variations
on is the theme is the rhythm that kevin
conroy was playing that whole time
he has been the kind of baseline melody
that
everyone else has been spinning off from
but like if you're thinking thematic
accuracy
to who batman should be and like yeah
batman comics over the years are mostly
designed for younger audiences the way
the animated series and the animated
films
are but at the end of the day he's still
simmering with rage
he's unforgiving he's pissed off he's
tireless he keeps fighting
you know like and he cracks a joke every
now and then batman
you wouldn't let me fry would you
[Music]
batman like he's like the perfect
balance
he came in third in our audience poll
and i think it's just because a lot of
people didn't know the name kevin conroy
yeah you know maybe haven't spent a lot
of time with the character edit score
other than the most popular movies
so he gets an eight out of ten but that
brings his total just above christian
bale to 55 out of six wow
okay he is our number one definitive
batman i get it
i i can't disagree with that so where do
you think uh robert pattinson will
will rank here you know i'm very
interested because i think that it could
go
in two different directions i think he
could
do a very christian bale level
performance
where he can do the kind of like
schmucky bruce wayne who's like
really kind of a mess kind of a
believable ceo though like
like especially when it was inherited a
company or i could see him
doing the michael keaton kind of
everyman batman thing
come on let's get nuts because robert
pattins is pretty funny too
you know like that is like he is
underratedly funny
and i could see him being funny in the
way michael keaton was funny as batman
i'm really excited for it to be honest i
i i think he's going to be
i think his uh his intelligence level
might
go down a little bit but i think his uh
theatrics
and i think his gear and his fighting
skills
are going to go up the intelligence
thing is kind of forgivable when you
consider that this is supposed to be
according to matt reeves it's supposed
to be like his second year of being
batman right like this is right right
right you can chalk it up didn't
experience
um i think the the real debate is gonna
be like is it better than batfleck
you just stopped me and we'll find out
we'll find out because that was
originally
a bad math like role right like he was
writing it at one point right you're
always gonna compare those two because
of that
so well i'm sure you've already
commented down below but
if you haven't yet feel free to let us
know how you would rank these
first off thanks to our friends at hero
health remembering to take daily
medication can be tough
and if you're caring for someone else
and managing their medication
that's like fighting the entire rogues
gallery of villains all at once
you need some help in this fight and
that help is called hero
hero is your medicine cabinet reinvented
the hero pill dispenser
sorts all daily medications and delivers
them all with the push of a button if
medication isn't taken
the hero app will send a notification to
you a family member or caregiver
so a dose is never missed hero makes it
simple and easy to make sure you or your
loved ones stay on track
and get the right meds at the right time
every time your hero membership includes
the app the pill dispenser and 24 7
support for just a dollar a day
hero even has an optional service that
delivers medication directly to your
door
never miss a dose again and always have
peace of mind with hero
right now if you go to herohealth.com
big
question you'll get 50 off initiation
fee
and a 30 day risk free trial with a
money back guarantee
that's herohealth.com bigquestion to
start your membership with 50
off and a 30 day free trial don't forget
that's herohealth.com
bigquestion and now we're going to move
on to some bite-sized questions that
tommy's going to answer are you ready
buddy
let's go i'm ready civiliander on
discord asks oh he's asking great
questions
if magneto's metal helmet is enough to
stop professor x from reading his mind
how can
charles xavier see through wolverine's
adamantium coated skull
it's not what magneto's helmet is made
out of that's so important we know
he can actually remake it out of scrap
metal it's what he does to it that makes
it telepath proof magneto reshapes the
metal
at a molecular level so it has
anti-psionic abilities
you remember learning about anti-psionic
abilities in your biology class right
that's the basic yeah yes the metal is
likely highly magnetized
since uh strong magnetic fields can
reduce or prevent telepaths from being
able to read minds
this is kind of similar to a real world
faraday cage
if you know what i'm saying guys yes
prevent signals from getting in and out
yeah
[Music]
yeah so we all we all have at times used
magnets to keep telepaths from getting
to us
uh that's that's been my excuse for why
i needed to stay up from school since i
was little and using magnetic fields
so technically magneto doesn't even need
the helmet on to protect his mind from
being red
active use of his power could just do
the same thing so he could just be
you know firing it up the helmet allows
him to not focus any effort on
protecting his mind
and that and that gives them an extra
layer of protection against alpha level
telepaths like jean grey
or professor x and beta level telepaths
like me
tomesto the mind master
[Laughter]
interesting interesting um all right our
third question comes from
uh glenn who he said is not his name but
that's what he's called on discord he
asked
the wizards in harry potter are supposed
to have longer life spans than muggles
but in the final scene of deathly
hallows we see that they have kids
roughly the same age as
we do so how does menopause work in the
wizarding world
great question glenn one i've stayed up
at night
losing sleepover figuring out the
menstrual cycles of those
damn wizards uh wizards have an average
lifespan of 137 and three-quarter
years how do i know this i looked it up
a human woman's fertility
is proportional to her aging so
presumably the longer the lifespan
the longer the fertility period right
incorrect
it does not appear that wizards age more
slowly throughout their lives
eleven-year-old harry and ron and her
money don't appear to be younger than
eleven-year-old dudley
puberty hits them at the same time as it
does for muggles
37 year old harry ron and hermione
looked like normal 37 year olds which is
not true
daniel radcliffe looked ridiculous with
his cgi
but they were aiming for 37. he did look
older
i think he looked like he could have
been 51 yeah he looked like he he looked
like the guy that works at the halloween
costume store that do like he just
doesn't go out in the sun a lot so like
all the lack of getting vitamin d
has made his hair just kind of looking
like it's just resting on him as opposed
to being there
very specific person i'm talking about
ron's just fat
yeah rupert grant they just made him fat
yeah which which is i mean
listen i'm almost 37 and i'm pretty fat
so let's see you're looking great by the
way thanks very much guys much
appreciated thank you eric so if
anything
the age makeup on harry made him look
even older so there's no evidence of
wizards having kids
at older ages or as a cultural trend
although remus lupin was pretty old when
he knocked up talks
but you think it would be a big thing in
their world like if women could have
kids in their 50s and 60s that would
completely change wizard society
that's a good point so they totally
would if they could so many more women
in the workforce and fewer witches
giving up their careers
in their 20s to raise families like you
know like human women are pressured to
do
that's true i like calling them human
women because it sounds like i'm not
human like when i observe human women
uh they're always quitting their jobs i
just want to meet a human woman for once
i'm bringing home a human woman to my
mom this christmas to show her that i
can be in a healthy relationship
all right so once wizards reach old age
they're just as likely to die from one
of the many maladies that tend
to cause death in elderly muggles they
stay spry
they do like everything i mean like you
know dumbledore was no slouch
so witches might have a slightly longer
fertility period due to improved general
health
but they're probably not having kids at
an advanced age it's probably just
the burden of having to support your
failure to launch wizard's son
well into his 70s that's more of a
burden to them when you're like 103
you're just like ah
all right i'll pay your cell phone bill
again but you realize you could just
communicate
through fireplaces right you do know you
can just use that for free what's your
name
that's brynette lovely name can you tell
me where you are at the moment
thank you for answering those questions
tom we are now we now have time for one
more
box to scraps question bunch of scraps
have you ever been a crime fighter like
batman
i i i was torn between a couple of
stories here but i will tell
a story of trying to do the right thing
and having it blow up in my face so like
potentially what would create a batman
villain
when i was in college i lived in a house
i think we talked about this before but
i live in a bunch of like very frat
house-y environments where people were
just constantly
constantly hammered uh and one of my
roommates
we'll just call him the human tornado he
was just a dis he was like a destructive
force of nature
he got super super super drunk and ended
up getting in a fight
and getting his ass kicked and then
coming over to me
and i was like holy [ __ ] like he was
bleeding out of his nose
bleeding out of his ears and he was
really really really messed up
so he wanted to call the police so i
called the police for him thinking like
i'll save the day
i'll call the police i'll get him
medical attention like i didn't know
like maybe if his nose was broken or if
he had like a brain injury
batman of you tommy yeah you know i call
i alerted commissioner gordon
i think you're trying to help
i'll save the day the police came and
when the police came there
my roommate was so drunk and messed up
that he told the police i was the one
who attacked him
like they were like they're like do you
know who did this to you and he just
went
he did and they were like they looked at
me
and i was like betrayal he was the one
who called you
why would i call you if i was like and
they were like nice try mister and then
they looked at my perfectly smooth hands
they're like these aren't fighting hands
and they let me go but
these have never done uh any physical
things in their lives
these hands have never touched man or
woman but uh but they were
i think i think honestly what happened
if i remember was like i was like
are you sure like i looked at him and i
was like are you sure you want to say
that he's like no no he didn't
it wasn't him like he changed he
recanted immediately but i was like
i was so furious because i was so mad
you
started kicking his back so then i took
him inside and beat the [ __ ] out of him
no
that was a story of trying to do the
right thing trying to save the day
uh that ultimately blew up in my face a
little bit uh how about you
i once uh i once considered myself a
batman and tried to join their ranks
because before i decided to move out to
la and and try to do improv
on herald teams to tommy bechtold yeah i
decided
i wanted to try to be a lawyer so the
summer before my senior year
uh of college in jacksonville florida i
interned for the state attorney's office
oh okay and i had a friend who was a
prosecutor who
was great guy um who got me this job and
i was like i'm gonna go to law school
i'm gonna be a lawyer and the state
attorney at the time
pretty high profile prosecuted a very
high profile case a couple years later
but her claim to fame was that she had
the best
uh conviction to death row record oh
cool so i i
i was like all right she knows what
she's doing um
but what they had the interns do that
summer was prosecute uh not prosecute we
were just following up on worthless
checks
so in the south for like a long period
of time
you could go to places like walmart and
the grocery store um
publix and you could write yourself a
check
for 75 and they would cash it yes that
was just their store policy
and a lot of people ripped them off it's
something that the the state attorney's
office is like
stop doing that stop sending us these
police reports
change your policy because people are
ripping you up so we had
all these backlog cases from like 1998
through like
2008 of all these cases and they had the
interns go through and try to clear them
out just to make some money back to call
people up
and scare them into paying off their ah
very smart okay even though a lot of
these things bench warrants had been
expired
people don't know that you just have an
intern kind of a scary letter or make a
scary phone call
but i felt so guilty doing this i'm so
non-confrontational
so we would have these case files and
like i would
call people and then like hang up
because i was just afraid of like
sure scaring them into doing this and
most of the time they don't pick up or
the or the phone
line isn't accurate anymore um but they
had like a
law student who was also an intern who
was kind of like in charge of us
who wanted to try to motivate made us
and turn it into like a glengarry glen
ross
they're like the most people who can
bring in or the most dollars you can
bring in on these worthless check files
oh my god you um you'll get like a 10
gift card to chili's at the end because
we weren't paid we were right
sure just to get us to do it i don't
know if that's okay to do that no but
it's just like a little
bonus i don't know but i was too afraid
i did want that chili's gift card though
um but i had like the lowest numbers
because what i would do i would sit in a
cubicle away from everyone else because
everyone else would really get into it
all these other
prospective law students are like yeah
i'm gonna be i'm gonna be the super
lawyer i'm gonna
you know they were all about that
carrying out justice and me i'm like i
don't know if i like this
and at one point uh the guy in charge of
us pulled me aside he's like hey
so you haven't gotten any case files
uh closed this week and i was like i
know i was hoping no one would notice
so i was so nervous uh there was one
case file that no one could get a hold
of this person
and this person was like the baron of
last
checks from like 2000 to 2002.
had like 14 different cases of doing
that yeah and was able to just like
stay off the grid and no one could find
him so that case file was on the high
shelf
and i'm like i'm gonna do that one so i
i i tried i spent all my time like this
is my white whale
yeah i wrote down i you can't take the
case files home but i wrote down some
um details of like his name and his last
known number
and uh because we couldn't use facebook
on the computers in the office i took it
on my personal facebook
and i was able to find him on facebook
on my home computer oh my god i
use this information and i tracked him
down i got back in the office the next
day i was able to find a phone number
for him
but it wasn't his facebook it was like a
relative's facebook
so i was like i'm gonna call the
relative uh so i call the relative
and the woman's voice uh she picks up
and she's like
yeah and i'm like excuse me are you uh
aware of this person and i think it was
like his spouse or something
and she's like uh yes i know who that is
i'm like well are you aware that he has
a bench warrant out for his arrest for
14
worthless checks he wrote and he got
away with and
you know we can refile the bench warrant
and she goes
he passed away last year oh
no and i was like oh and i was like
i had heard i had heard that some of the
other interns were like people will try
to claim that
yeah sure so i doubled down and i said
yeah right
oh god she sent me a link to like
oh god it's obituary
and i found it they ask you how you are
you just have to say that you're fine
when you're not really fine but you just
can't get into it because they would
never understand oh no
but something happened where i think
because i went after after that after
the internship was over i was so freaked
out by it that i
like it was like this isn't for me the
life of law
yeah i don't have i don't the stomach
for it i'm too much of a soy boy
yeah me too buddy
and i got uh these thank you letters to
all the interns
they they went out to all of us and the
thank you note they sent to me was like
eric you have the highest number of
closed cases i think they still
attributed that white whale to me
so you got the gift card i uh yeah i got
the gift card
they're like eric out ranked all of our
other interns
i had this reputation at the higher ups
thinking that i was like going after
these people cracking skulls
eric the bounty hunter er you you just
you sent that guy's wife
a letter that just said check me and
then it was avoided
it was avoided obituary that would be uh
they're like god that guy's ruthless i
wonder if like she went out and she came
back and paid the restitution because i
think
it was only like it was like a 600 bucks
or something like that yeah you know
yeah
so maybe she didn't they're like whoa we
got them i don't know what it was but
i'm batman you didn't twitter me you
took
yourself attacked and ripped off walmart
well that's our episode
so great to chat with you tommy we
figured out who the best batman is
and which uh between us is the best
batman and you're my favorite batman
for sure you're my favorite batman no
thank you i swear to you
you're mine and i swear back
reminder to all of you that you can join
our official discord by becoming a
patron at patreon.comrockstars and on
discord that's where we see the bulk of
our question submission so if you really
want to get our attention with a
question
join discord ask us there we got a whole
server
channel set up for that and then if you
want to hit us up on twitter we might
see it there at hashtag
bigquestion is your best chance of
getting our attention follow me at eavos
on instagram you can follow tommy at
tommy bechtold follow new rockstars and
social subscribe here on youtube
to get too much information on all the
stuff you care about thanks for watching
goodbye see you next week
[Music]
you